half at this end this is the wire
auto-completed it's 50 cent engaged to
Miranda Hart no we did have a good thing
though she tackled me and I film we shot
Budapest it's finishing up now last time
I checked that was a full-blown pill but
you know I'm reformed I'm recovering
what does Fitness service they just salt
well then the song was called still
think I'm nothing featuring John Mayer
yes fitness center nice guy absolutely I
love for descent same day what about him
but it's a good guy it's 50 cent taking
over bTW absolutely it's 50 cent a
billion it absolutely not
on the way there on my way there buddy
still stacking a few chips it's 50 cent
Jamaican nope I was born in Southside
Jamaica but American it's 50 cent really
dead I'm alive and in the flesh baby you
see it's 50 cent and moonlight what's
that the movie
my music my 50 cent event vitamin water
no I didn't event vitamin water
they 50-cent invent mixtapes no but I
evolved mixtapes the fitness it made a
bet with Kanye West yeah did everybody
know I didn't make a bet with Kanye was
250 set retire I'll be working every day
I'm just doing a little bit of different
stuff that diversified if 50 cent used
to box yep I still kick somebody ass
right now they try me all you gotta do
is try me
cuz I snap and you can get your lawsuit
like look right here does 50 said have a
I'm the only child I my mama's only baby
so it does 50 set ask 21 questions
I did when they liked the song so yeah
keep popping up day 50 said in his back
tattoo no I didn't I love to bake 50 on
the back 50 Southside shots baby does 50
cent know what a great foodies
always comedians did that he was just
says but you have to be stupid to think
that I didn't know what a great food is
right one second I've got a big movie
dinner button these phone calls I'm
starting to feel important around here
where is 50 cent
Africa house well your mama's like that
that's why Rocco
where does 50 cent his name I got off
the street it's a nickname where was 50
said born I was born in Jamaica Hospital
on Southside Jamaica Queens where they
fit they said died 50 cent died and a
relationship with this girl back us
outside to meet the class man well women
you may die a million deaths
we always fit the set window shop off
filmed all was filming the South of
France Monaco the 50 cent go to college
no didn't fortunately enough time for
college I was busy says if 50 said not
Mayweather out no I'm not flirting out
should have knocked flowed out kind of
hard to hit chap even when he's standing
right in front of you stop moving in to
show the block everything soon me hard
to hit the 50 said no notorious b.i.g no
I didn't have an opportunity to meet him
but we did do mashup song would call the
Rayleigh's
the 50 cent cranes to show power yes I
did create to show power me and Courtney
Kemp collaborated and develop the entire
service the 50 cent trapped by the high
school I dropped out momentarily all
your return to get my GED what is 50
cent age
I'm currently 31 years old and going
backwards like Benjamin Button I'll be
30 next year people don't even worry
about it
what is
50 cent candy shop about see this is
when you try to get me to talk dirty but
I'm not gonna do it
candy shop is about enjoying the fruits
of nature
this is a hell no I'm not him I'm
sorry guys for this 50 said like the
real life I think yeah isn't that bad
intentions unless you do something let's
finish it left handed yep okay that was
it it's cool answering your guys
questions and that's it for wild
autocomplete keep it locked right here